[Music]
kiss me again
why don't you kissed a girl
come on and kiss the girl go on and kiss
the girl
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
to the above World a man was drowning I
had to save him this obsession with
humans has to stop I just want to know
more about them
[Music]
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
watching you see me
someday I'll be
[Music]
he said you look you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
[Music]